ich habe mich heute aufgeregt über den
umgang der cdu mit armin laschet denn
vor einer woche wohl ist nur geflüstert
und
jetzt hat sich die kritik am kanzler
kandidaten der union in ein opfer
verwandelt putschpläne in der cdu sie
titelte heute die frankfurter allgemeine
zeitung in ihrer online ausgabe auch
bild und auch spiegel online berichteten
ähnlich und alle die irgendwie noch was
zu sagen haben in der cdu reden von der
personellen erneuerung an der
parteispitze die jetzt sein muss alle
allerdings ohne armin laschet dabei beim
namen zu nennen egal ob merkbaren
röttgen keiner von ihnen sagt das
naheliegende nämlich dass es mit armin
da steht wieder ein neubeginn noch eine
aussichtsreiche
funktionierendes jamaika koalition geben
könnte für mich zeigt dass die ware
schwäche der union nämlich
hasenfüßigkeit der führungsperson die
sich nicht trauen offen auszusprechen
was ist das eben mit kam im schnitt kein
staat oder auch keine jamaika koalition
hinzubekommen ist das zu sagen ist hart
auch weil armin laschet sich eingesetzt
hat für die cdu ist hat einen harten
wahlkampf hinter sich gebracht aber es
wäre fairer zumindest als das friendly
fire was ihm dauernd aus dem rücken in
den rücken gefeiert wird und denn nur
wenn die union jetzt ein schnell
neuanfang macht und einen neuen
hoffnungsträger ins rennen schickt gibt
es eine berechtigte
überlegung hier merkte doch noch
hinzubekommen
der grund
der grund hier würde ich erst mal
zustimmen dass der umgang mit armin
laschet gerade in weiten teilen schäbig
ist und ich halte von rücktritts
rücktrittsforderung in diesem zustand
überhaupt nichts weil sonst keinen
millimeter weiter bringen ich glaube
aber dass die schwäche dieses benannt
haben nicht unsere haupt schwäche ist
sondern die schwäche für mich als cdu
darin ist in den letzten monaten jahren
geworden dass wir nicht mehr intern
streiten das war große stärke der union
fand ich dass wir es geschafft haben
unsere internen streitereien hinter
verschlossenen türen zu führen
geschlossene symbolisiert was wir mal so
richtig aber das krasse ist doch wann
war das denn wahr den mantel geschlossen
im wahlkampf die spd das ist doch für
mich irre gewähren das haben wir nicht
mehr geschafft diese geschlossenheit zu
symbolisieren
ja wir lieben ganz krasses zeichen dafür
jetzt gab es ja die ja die
vorbereitenden gespräche auch zwischen
union und fdp das durchstechen ganze und
hier gibt es offenkundig gilt hat
darüber exklusiv berichtet
durchstechereien die fdp ist außer sich
vielleicht den größten ihrer sachen
stelle fdp und spd fahne stille grüne
und spd verhandeln stille und die union
nicht mit und plötzlich wird wieder
durch gestochen und dafür kann bild
nichts ich würde es jetzt schon ist
genauso
aber es geht von unseren sturm mich hat
das schon in der ersten fraktionssitzung
so an genervt weil ich mir dachte ihr
habt gar nichts gelernt leute eine
ersten fraktionssitzung schon die
wortmeldung wieder zu protokollieren
quasi überrannt haben wir bei twitter da
krieg ich ein anfang auf der einen seite
freue ich mich auf los davon
mitzubekommen
auf der anderen seite das ist genau der
fehler den wir im wahlkampf schon
gemacht haben aber diese mangelnde
geschlossen das doch alles sehr
durchsichtig mit ich werde diesen dieser
entschuldigung die parole von der man
geschlossen will ich in meinem leben nie
wieder hören ich muss ich wahrscheinlich
noch eine million mal hören weil
parteien sind nicht dazu da geschlossen
zu sein vielleicht einem wahlkampf
ansonsten sollen sie verdammt noch mal
diskutieren das ist das was die eu lange
nicht gemacht hat sie hat sich aber
nichts mehr auseinander gesetzt in der
sache und nun haben wir es ja wenn man
das uns angucken wer sich hier
öffentlich meldet sind das alles
potenzielle nachfolger jedenfalls
glauben sie dass von sich das sind alles
und zwar ausschließlich männer die sich
zutrauen den oder unbedingt wollen den
armin laschet dem ersten ritt hat eine
frau gefahren also ja ja die will aber
nichts werden und das war auch nicht
erheblich aber jetzt sind alle die
unterwegs sie war es werden wollen also
herr röttgen dem hätte ich das nun diese
billige tour gar nicht zugetraut weil
das ein sehr intelligenter analytisch
begabter mensch ist der sich nun dadurch
selbst verbrannt hat ich glaube wenn die
einen ausgemacht hätten unter sich wer
ihm nachfolgen soll wer der armin
laschet schon gestürzt aber das haben
sie nicht sondern sie sind entschlossen
gegeneinander anzutreten
das gibt so ein guevara das sonst macht
sondern macht die fusion die unklar
lässt wer denn der nachfolger sein wird
und unter solchen bedingungen stürzt
einer nur dann wenn ein schweren kater
noch schwereren katastrophe bizarr und
jetzt gesetzlich aussage der armin
laschet ist wie ein fahrrad solange das
noch in bewegung es und trudelt noch ein
bisschen ist alles in ordnung aber wenn
es stehen bleibt fällt um und wenn gerne
aus den sondierungen rauskommt und hat
nichts erreicht und bleibt stehen feld
herum und dann muss man sehen was die
union damit anfängt er wird jährlich ab
jetzt sagen wir auch noch eine chance zu
wahren überhaupt darauf da in jamaika
koalition irgendwas hinzubekommen denn
ist ja offenkundig wie armin laschet
jetzt gerade dieser wert wird egal ob
von röttgen gestern abend oder von von
merz oder von jemandem wie sparen wir
zwei andere vorschickt tobias hans und
dann günther und in wirklichkeit sicht
meint aber irgendwann ist dann bleibt
das fahrrad stehen und dann gibt die
ganze cdu mit um ja da ist genau jetzt
hat ihm die karten auch keine jamaika
koalition führen sie es nicht in dem
zustand eine bundesregierung zu bilden
das ist doch auch eine ganz simple lehre
aus dem was wir jetzt seit einer woche
sehen
einer woche ich fand der ganze wahlkampf
hatte oft was von box den laschet also
natürlich gab es auf der einen seite
diese chöre
armin laschet mit kanzler die waren aber
ehrlich gesagt auch wenn ich mal etwas
zum schmunzeln die waren etwas drüber
man hat uns und schön ausgedrückt es war
etwas glücklich war ich kann an einer
datei ich war ganz wichtig es war
wirklich mussten auch gesungen ich habe
es auch gesungen aber
das ist doch genau der punkt und das
habe ich auch den börsen europe können
das ist auch der körper nicht die
menschen am wahlkampfstand habe erzählen
können ich habe aber trotzdem
innerparteilich wahlkampf gemacht und da
sind wir übrigens bei der inhaltlichen
auseinandersetzung deswegen fand ich den
prozess sogar weil wir erstmals drei
männer aus einer partei am tisch hatten
die allen anderen ansatz hatten das war
nicht sehr schön ich hab dann wahlkampf
für markus söder gemacht habe zweimal
als auch gegen arminia kohle für den
folgen danach auch gesagt vielleicht
langsam
dass wir uns den leuten am stand
erzählen konnte ist das mich armin
laschet begeistert hat und das ich
unterschätzt aber nach wie vor ort
gewesen und wo gemacht weil ich
innerhalb von drei monaten warum weil
ich jedes mal irgendwo von der rede
stand und mir dachte borgen okay was
vorgesorgt mal gucken was armin da steht
jetzt sagen wird und hinterher
dachten schon sagen dass ich ein
ansatzpunkt also du warst ja sozusagen
positiv überrascht weil du ihn als nicht
kompetent oder fähig genug arminia
schatz größte stärke war da war und ist
dass er unterschätzt wird glaube ich der
man kann ganz viel und deswegen traue
ich ihm auch ich finde auch nicht dass
mit armin laschet kein staat zu machen
ist sondern mit dem ist staat zu machen
hat mich überzeugen kost und ich habe
zwei macht ist hat sich jemand anderen
fragen ganz thüringen
sagen meine bundestagsabgeordnete hat
auch ordentlich für aminata
schon 2 aber diese dieses box den
laschet war das nicht wirklich am ende
ich fand wirklich das hatte was ich
meine er dass er sich im top box mit
boxhandschuhen stilisiert weiß auch
nicht die grünende der pr arbeit im
wahlkampf würde ich sagen aber er hat es
nicht wirklich was werden nicht so
nieder geboxt hätte innerparteilich
viele freunde von mir damals immer
gesagt ich kann den nicht will nena
ihnen findet nicht mal seine eigene
partei gut deswegen was passiert denn es
muss irgendwie lehre daraus gezogen
werden wie auch mit einer umgang wird ja
genau das ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt
und das sorry dass ich das sage aber das
ist diese geschlossenheit über die wir
reden müssen und am ende hieß es hat
auch mein mann hat diese gesamten
demoskopen gesehen und jeder demoscope
einem gesagt auch bei diesem kopf an
kopf rennen am ende gewinnt derjenige
oder die partei die sich an geschlossen
hinter ihrem kandidaten versammeln kann
und das haben wir nicht geschafft aber
nein wir sehen wenn sie eine bild
meldung jetzt durch gestochen wird als
sie haben ja gesagt alle halten dicht
und die fdp 2 und und ist also recht
völlig völlig sauer weil diese
diskretion eigentlich bei den anderen
gesprächen mit grünen mit der spd
gewahrt bleibt und hier wo ist da noch
die aspiranten gibt es damit uns gibt es
die größte inhaltliche übereinstimmung
damit dass die serviert und eben auch
kaputt gemacht fall ja wir wollen ja mal
was gutes an unserem beruf unterstellen
es gibt journalisten recherchieren was
ja also die lassen sich nicht was stehen
sondern die finden was raus aber es
sollte auch mal unterstellen dass der
bild mensch was rausgefunden hat wer
weiß überhaupt das land das dadurch
gestochen wird aber noch mal zurück zur
armin laschet wenn
das nicht seit dem wahlabend eine
minimale aussicht darauf gibt dass es
noch sondierungen mit den anderen beiden
parteien gibt und für eine minimale dass
man vielleicht doch noch irgendeine
regierung bildet und sei es am ende eine
große koalition wenn es nicht so wäre
wäre der mann schon am wahlabend
gestürzt eigentlich da zurücktreten
müssen nach dieser niederlage
wer übernimmt eigentlich noch
verantwortung für sowas desaströses
signal warnt er ist aufgestanden gesagt
ich habe den ich nehme ich habe den
anspruch eine regierung zu bilden das
ist ja verrückt es seit seit aber uli
hätten gedankt zum beispiel christian
lindner damals als leiter chef des
bundeskanzleramtes unter helmut kohl der
innenminister war in minnesota ist doch
zu real wollte ja gerade krank so seit
er zurückgetreten ist war gar nicht
persönlich schuld wegen des
gescheiterten polizeieinsatzes gegen die
raf in bad kleinen ist er feiner mann
wie er ist zurückgetreten hat die
politische verantwortung übernommen seit
dieser zeit gibt es dann eigentlich wohl
beantworten zum beispiel 2017 christian
lindner hat gesagt lieber nicht regieren
als falschen gehen das würde wurde in
meiner ansicht nach kaum gedanken eher
was für ein versager move vielleicht und
das war ja eigentlich das was man von
politikern fordert mensch sein
verantwortung zu übernehmen auch mal
nicht den ministerposten ansicht dass
sowohl ihm aber nicht gedacht das war
für die fdp ein sehr sehr wagemutiger
move denn die fdp ist im positiven sinne
eine klientel partei sie bekommt stimmen
damit sie was verändert und deswegen
geben menschen ihr die stimme und
erwarten dass auch von und dann zu sagen
moment da machen wir nicht mit in
erwartung dass sie das schlimmste
verhindern würde das waren natürlich
wirklich hätte die fdp auch existenziell
gefährden können ganz geschafft heraus
zu kommen und das muss man anerkennen
das war tatsächlich ein mutiger move der
hätte auch richtig schiefgehen können
[Musik]